the chemistry between you and Dwayne is
beautiful it's scary and beautiful
because all families are like that right
yeah this issues in all families and to
see that rich or the Siva tell ritual it
is beautifully done I'm assuming there
was a lot of rehearsal behind it what
was it like for you to see it in its
complete for the first time jacked it
was shot Jeff I'm only up it just felt
good yeah everything about it felt good
and just to see it translating just to
see it you know on the big screen it
just both I don't really see DJ step up
and look at our staff table whoa in his
lava lava yes shirtless yeah it was
great yeah amen to tone of the voice
because there's a scene where I think
it's a pivotal moments you and Dwayne
fighting side-by-side I mean that must
have been scary for you as one of your
first debut acting gigs it was cool yeah
you know I don't know if we're ever
gonna be able to you know chop it up in
the ring ever again
so to be able to do it on set and just
just to be in there and and what felt
like could be some wrestling for us you
know it that mean that's the that's kind
of the family business for us so for us
to pay homage and just have that and
yeah I mean just to be in tune with each
other you know just answering each each
other's questions and just knocking
people out left and right it was a
really cool moment that was real isn't
it that was like that that's what
happened that that's what would happen
in real life if anybody wants to step up
that's what happens right there so watch
the movie because you don't know great
moment to with the Mamas you're the
Silver Slipper and that's for the
slipper I mean growing up did you cause
any mischief
oh me never know you're a good kid I can
see you be good my mom yeah I'm never
doing it you
I had a little run of being the class
clown I just I've discovered my voice in
the Northeast give me some dick oh god I
well I was just a loud kid you know I
went to where yes you would Duane cause
issues huh no he was a good kid I
wouldn't miss it
Duane's mom no no I met her when we did
this Eva time yeah she brings an album
R&R if you seen this album that she has
models of the Duane when he's a baby and
she should everybody have you seen it
yeah I think you are maybe you are does
this mean your ticket transition into
acting will you think about leaving WWE
full-time and doing this and following
your cousin's footsteps I think I just
want to take advantage of every
opportunity that I have right now you
know I feel good I'm still you know
young enough and athletic I feel great
so I wanted to be able to take advantage
to you know maximize what I do in the
ring as long as I can I'm pretty much
you know if you're a wrestling fan I'm
gonna run it to the wheels fall off you
know I'm not gonna lie about it I can't
do it forever but when the time is right
I feel like it is a natural transition
and if I can handle it then why not you
know I'm always down to do it you know
when you're driving down the road in
your car and you're having that moment
of cruising what's the song you like to
listen to
well I somewhere over the rainbow is
sabab yeah well bye Izzie yeah yeah yeah
I know
[Music]
let's top it sounded good in these ears
yeah